[Music]  here was some money saving Super Bowl  party tips is our prop master bill tow  bill take some packing peanuts spray  paint um orange boom cheese doodles  [Applause]  here's bill with another tip bill take a  hotdog stick it in a sock boom pigs in a  blanket here's bill with another one  take some binoculars watch your  neighbor's having sex boom halftime show  and another one take a regular TV  surround it with all furniture boom  big-screen TV and another one take a  bowl of white beans turn out the lights  boom black bean dip take your ten year  old nephew give them a microphone boom  Bob Costas how is that a party tip it  doesn't even make watch an exciting play  of some kerosene boom  slow-motion replay take some nachos  write out your two best friends in a  murder trial  boom Ray Lewis nachos  you  [Applause]